just breaking in the last few minutes
the the entire
england cricket team are having to
self-isolate
uh because seven members of the squad
that's three players
and four members of the management team
have tested positive for kobe 19s that
seven of them have tested positive so
the rest naturally are having to
self-isolate
and this two days before england are due
to play pakistan
at the start of a one day international
series with three 2020 matches to come
after that
what are they going to do the series
will go ahead they'll need the money
so they're going to pick as of now
they're working on it now
a new squad they'll announce it in the
next few years completely new squad
uh it'll be captained by ben stokes who
wasn't involved
in the original squad and um
the obviously the incoming players will
be tested so will the pakistan players
what england have done is slightly relax
the very very tight bubble restrictions
which have been causing concern for some
of the players
about the mental well-being of players
you'll be aware that sportsmen around
the world have had
that kind of a problem so the chief
executive officer of the
of the cricket board tom harrison says
quote uh we've been mindful that the
emergence of the delta variants along
with the move away
from the stringent enforcement of
biosecure environments
could increase the chances of an
outbreak we made a strategic choice
to try to adapt protocols in order to
support the well-being of our players
and management staff
who've spent much of the last 14 months
living in very restricted
conditions but there's obviously a risk
with that
and they are now paying the price one
squad is going to lie
into isolation and right now they're
working on calling up a new one